hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that asked questions of my
flash and arrow stuff this week I'm also
going to include Supergirl legends of
tomorrow stuff too just because they
dropped their trailer so there's a whole
bunch of stuff to talk about I'm gonna
start with this schedule like when all
these shows are gonna premiere just
going in order flash and arrow are gonna
premiere first they'll be like the same
week they premiered last year that first
week in October that could get bumped by
a week or two but generally it's gonna
be the exact same time they premiered
last year Supergirl isn't premiering
till November on CBS remember that's a
different network the reason it's not
starting till November is because of
Thursday Night Football I know that
sounds weird
they have another show that's in
supergirls timeslot that's gonna run for
about eight weeks once Thursday night
football is over that show that's in
supergirls place is moving to Thursdays
and Supergirl will start week eight of
the NFL games is like the last weekend
in October so Supergirl will probably
premiere the first week in November
that's November 2nd legends of tomorrow
isn't gonna start till January when
arrow and flash come back but all three
of those shows on the CW will run at the
same time what's probably gonna happen
is is they'll put it on a different
night so it'll be like flash then arrow
then legends of tomorrow
think about the crossovers that happen
this year between arrow and the flash so
you like you have something happen on
the flash and then they'd address it on
arrow so what'll probably happen is or
at least what I'm hoping they do is that
something bad happens on the flash it
carries over to arrow and then the
Superfriends fix it on legends of
tomorrow on the last night all of the
shows will cross over to a certain
degree Barry and Oliver will go on
legends of tomorrow I don't know which
legends of tomorrow characters will go
on arrow in the flash though they're
shooting legends of tomorrow this summer
I'm hoping that they have some more
footage to show off at Comic Con so
we'll see they did announce that they
would be doing like a big flare o-type
crossover like they did last year
between air on the flash where they
share a villain they did all kinds of
crossovers this season but usually it's
like a very self-contained small story
the flash versus arrow Captain Boomerang
story was way way bigger so they're
gonna do like one of those each year
just like last year it's gonna be
episodic of tomorrow doesn't start till
January I don't think that flash versus
arrow story will have anything to do
with legends of tomorrow but they will
set up the plot
of legends of tomorrow by the mid-season
finale of both the flash and arrow both
the shows will set up what's happening
in the spin-off show so even if there's
like one show that you like way more
than the other like if you're a bigger
fan of the flash and arrow I recommend
that you watch both shows for context
it's like if you're reading DC's big
convergent storyline right now they have
the main comic but then they also have
like the satellite tie-in titles no
surprise that a bunch of comic book TV
shows would start to work like big comic
book events and everybody's still
wondering who the J Jackson character is
on legends of tomorrow he wasn't in the
trailer right now I'm thinking black
lightning or static shock in the bio for
the character it said he was a star
athlete and a bit of a wisecracker
because they didn't call the show
Justice Society or Justice League it
makes me think that they're doing
characters that aren't appearing in the
movies like they're trying to avoid
movie stuff in general so I don't think
that he's playing cyborg looking at the
general makeup of the team it looks like
they picked characters that had
relatively different looking powers so I
don't think there's gonna be two
speedsters on the team Barry Allen's
gonna be part of the show so I don't
think that J Jackson is Wally West
they just started teasing coast city and
if they ever did do Green Lantern I
think they'd go with Silver Age Green
Lantern first just like they did with
Barry Allen the other they go with Hal
Jordan so I don't think he's Simon Baz
there are rumors that they might do Jay
Garrick you know flash a to world
situation they're jumping all over time
and space so that that could be the end
for multiverse you could look at the
alliteration is like a Wally West Easter
Egg like JJ 2ww but I think if they ever
did do wally west he would be called
wally west as much as the TV shows
change stuff about the comics they're
still very true to the name like Laurel
lance's the canary in the comics it's a
little bit different it's Dinah Laurel
Lance it's the same thing with Thea
being speedy you know being the Mia
Dearden character she's thea dearden
queen so jay jackson is probably not
wally west unless he has four names and
they just omitted the wally west part
under question so here we go griffin
blaze asks they mentioned fares air too
many times for it to just be a nod and a
wink and now they mentioned a test pilot
going missing
I think it's possibly leaving the door
open yeah I mean movie stuff TV stuff
very nebulous but I do think if they
ever did Green Lantern it would be Hal
Jordan Stephen Amell did
confirmed that they are rolling heavy on
coast city in season four of arrow so
the Hal Jordan universe like that you
know that area in the comics is becoming
a bigger and bigger thing it's gonna be
like a Candyman situation someone will
mention his name five times in the same
episode and poof he'll just appear
barring that though don't hold your
breath for a green lantern on TV anytime
soon just a whole lot more Green Lantern
related stuff next question on Sheik
asks will flashpoint happen within one
episode or over the course of a season
will they introduce wally west and will
Captain Boomerang collude with
Deathstroke I mean I definitely think
the Captain Boomerang will come back at
a certain point but they're not doing as
much Suicide Squad stuff in next season
because of the movie the back door to
Wally West I know just because it's
confusing because Joe West doesn't have
a son is flashpoint Barry Allen goes
back in time and then that changes the
character dynamics for season two of the
flash I kind of think that's the
direction they're going Tom Cavanagh was
at the CW up fronts he appears in the
trailer for legends of tomorrow so
that's a pretty good sign that he's
going to be in season two of the flash
and they can't do that unless they
dramatically change the character if
you've ever watched American Horror
Story I think it's gonna be kind of like
that you know same cast every year same
group of people but the characters are a
little bit different so like Tom
Cavanagh next year might be playing the
true version of Harrison wells like
Barry might end up saving him somehow
flashpoint in the comics was kind of
like a darkest timeline situation
I don't know how dark they're gonna go
on the flash but I do think all the
characters will shift based on like big
changes made in the timeline and that
could set the stage for Wally West to
appear somehow next question Peter asks
where was heatwave in this episode was
Dominic Purcell filming legends of
tomorrow stuff well I don't know about
that but usually when actors don't
appear in an episode it's either because
there wasn't room for them in the
narrative or they weren't available
usually it's the second reason it's like
they just weren't available as much fun
as it is having Dominic Purcell with
Wentworth Miller on screen I do think it
gave them more room to develop captain
Colts character because he's eby's very
different from heat wave heat wave would
never make a bargain with the flash the
way Captain cold would even though
Captain Cold totally double-crossed them
next question monkey warrior asks is it
possible that they were driving to coast
city in the end you
talking about arrow the background kind
of looked like the one when the flash
got pizza yeah
they're definitely going to Co city like
I said Stephen Amell confirmed coast
city gonna be a big thing in season four
that could be both flashbacks and
present day if you remember what Oliver
said in the episode they're like hey
where are you going and he said
hopefully somewhere far away from here
coast city is like on the opposite side
of the United States so that would
literally be far far away what I think
is gonna happen is is they'll do like a
version of longbow hunters when the
season picks up all around Felicity will
be in coast city I mean in longbow
hunters it was Seattle they'll just
they'll swap those cities they'll have
like their own mini arc there before
they come back to Starling city I do
think at some point in season four
Oliver will become the green arrow he
can't be the arrow anymore like Stephen
Amell
interviews that said arrow is done like
the name arrow isn't coming back but for
most of season four he'll probably just
be Oliver Queen solving problems until
eventually he takes the name green arrow
whenever they're planning TV shows
typically you know the goal is to hit
five seasons or 100 episodes for
syndication purposes they just they make
way more money when that happens so I
think that logically they wanted Oliver
to become green arrow going into season
five because they thought that that
might be the last season that doesn't
mean the arrow will stop after season
five they'll keep going as long as
Stephen Amell wants to keep going but I
don't think they're gonna do like
supernatural and go to like ten years
just like Smallville was always going to
put Clark in the costume during the last
season whatever that ended up being I
mean obviously it ended up being season
ten I think
arrow is doing the same thing where it's
like whatever the planned end point was
he's going to be Green Arrow but I do
think depending on how Stephen Amell
film career takes off they'll continue
to do arrow for like six maybe seven
seasons seven seasons is kind of the
magic number for cable and smaller shows
next question how can this guy asks what
about diggle's costume yeah there's so
much talk about diggle's costume
supposedly he's going to have like a
face covering next season I don't know
if you want to call that a costume or
not just wearing a mask there's a lot of
rumors that he might end up becoming the
Guardian character like that might be
the name he uses he wouldn't use the
name vigilante like that wouldn't sit
very well with Oliver like I said I
don't think that Green Lantern is gonna
become a big thing in the arrow universe
yet so I don't think he's gonna be Simon
Baz either even though
as does wear like a big face covering
odds are he won't have a name he'll just
be Diggle with a mask next question
Osama asks in the trailer when the time
machine is shown it shows Harrison wells
when you pause you can see I'm sitting
in the time chair does this mean that
he'll be in the new legends of tomorrow
series yes you actually we even see the
reverse-flash to the time chair itself
actually looks like something from HG
Wells as in the time traveller when the
flash first started and we found out
that he was playing Harrison wells a lot
of people took that as an HG Wells
reference as in he was a time traveler
turns out he was you just a Bart dawn
but since he's wearing the reverse-flash
suit I do believe this is a bard Thawne
in this chair Heil Bart Thawne is a time
traveler so it only makes sense that if
the characters travel all over time
they'd run into him somehow what they
might do like you know this kind of a
long shot just a theory that they might
retcon his backstory a little bit and
make a Barth on part of the time masters
organization if he's from the 25th
century that's not the case in the
comics but that time chair that he's
sitting in might belong to the time
masters
next question Ingrid says I just love
how Sarah raises up from the pit with
full makeup on about the show I don't
know how over with a 24 episode run if
it only it was a miniseries or had a
limited run so yeah so what's happening
is is it's 13 episodes it's gonna be
highly C relized
so think of it as a 13 hour movie broken
into one-hour episodes that's the way
they planned it that's the way they're
shooting it to be much more cinematic so
it works a lot more like a Netflix
series thank you so much everyone for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do I'll have to figure out how
I'm gonna do q and A's with so many DC
shows on but it shouldn't be too bad at
least in the fall there is one more
flash trailer so I might do a video for
that next be sure to subscribe to get it
I actually just realized I forgot to
include a bunch of Supergirl stuff in
this so yeah everyone was making it a
joke that the Supergirl trailer like the
six minutes of footage felt a lot like
that Black Widow SNL parody just
remember that shows end up looking very
different from what they do in trailers
and the people that make the shows don't
cut those trailers that's like that's a
marketing department really the people
they made that trailer for are people
that watch a lot of CBS TV shows but
have no idea who's Supergirl is the way
they're describing the character that
kind of gives some insight into the
is that she's a quirky eccentric
intelligent girl on a journey of
self-discovery figuring out how to be a
woman with superpowers yes the show is
loosely part of the Flair Oh or arrow
universe however you want to think about
it but CBS has said that they don't want
to do like a big flare o-type crossover
in season 1 so most of what you see will
be self-contained but in the future it
will probably crossover with air in the
flash in some way maybe not as big a
crossover as arrow in the flash but if
they ever did do something it would be
like a big cinematic event they actually
screen the arrow versus flash crossover
in theaters briefly just in terms of the
actual episodes think about what episode
1 of the flash looked like and what it
looks like now but the show has changed
quite a bit over 23 episodes usually
season 1 of every show like really any
show in general is when the writers are
figuring the characters out but I did
see some of you thought that this might
be a movie trailer no this is a TV
series and even if they do reference
Superman or we even see him on screen in
some fashion
it's not gonna be Henry Cavill it'll be
like the TV version of that they're not
gonna crossover with the movies that's
why it's not like super dark depressing
and gritty so in case you guys haven't
seen it you can click here for the
legends of tomorrow trailer you can
watch like 10 or 15 more times and you
can click here to catch up on the flash
before the finale next week thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight